this Friday hang on to me see the film  critics called Marvel Studios at its  best  now listen to them explain why and more  detail  Rolling Stone calls it's a wild summer  ride each laugh-out-loud funny epi  really [ __ ] it's out of this world  good wait it's out of what it's not a  poor at home guardians of the galaxy's  volume to a pretty pg-13 everywhere  Friday you know why I did it star much  mmm I can sir star much I did it because  I wanted to what are we even talking  about this for we just had a little man  save us by blowing up 50 ships how  little like this a little one-inch man  saved us well if he got closer I'm sure  he'd be much larger if it's how eyesight  works you stupid raccoon don't Collier  our code I'm sorry I took it too far  I meant trash Bandar is that better I  don't know  it's course it's so much worse  you